bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur les chaînes parlementaires pour
parlement hebdo avec aude moracchini
bonjour jean michaël bonjour à tous et
dans l'actualité cette semaine c'est le
feuilleton de la présidence ump une
pièce de théâtre avec des lots de
rebondissements sur fond de grand
déballage la vie françois fillon
accepter sa défaite avant de repartir à
l'attaqué en cause l'oubli du score de
trois fédérations de son côté jean
françois copé reste inflexible les deux
hommes s'affrontent avec 2017 comme
objectif
alain juppé est appelé à la rescousse il
devient larbitre de cette invasion
alors évidemment ce climat de guerre
s'étend aux parlementaires mercredi les
quatre colonnes à l'assemblée ont pris
les allures d'un drôle de champ de
bataille où les deux camps s'évitait et
multipliait les déclarations vengeresse
yat il menace de scission des groupes
parlementaires ump les députés ont
jusqu'au 30 novembre pour se décider
enfin est ce un nouveau couac ou à coup
politique françois hollande devant les
maires réunis en congrès évoque la
liberté de conscience pour les mères qui
procéderont au mariage pour tous le
lendemain il retient ses propos jugés
choquants dans sa propre majorité est
avec nous pour commenter cette actualité
jérôme chartier bonjour merci d'être est
député ump du val d'oise et on vous a
beaucoup vu cette semaine puisque vous
êtes le porte parole de françois fillon
dans cette période pour le moins agitée
on va évidemment consacré une grande
partie de l'émission à cette série un
épisode que vous nous offrez
mais auparavant c'est la règle on est
allé promener nos caméras aux quatre
colonnes voir ce que vos collègues
députés pensent êtes-vous échantillons
recueillis par chloé baïse ya quelqu'un
qui fait effectivement son boulot de
député
présent dans l'hémicycle qui dépose
l'amendement qui défend ses convictions
un vrai parlementaire j'ai beaucoup
observé quand je présidais à l'assemblée
nationale puisque je présidais les
travaux et qu'il était souvent en porte
parole du groupe ump pour les questions
budgétaires financières et il faisait
comme il le continue aujourd'hui un
excellent travail avec beaucoup
d'aisance et surtout une réflexion de
fond
quelqu'un qui a clairement des valeurs
qui ne pense clairement pas comme moi
sur de nombreux sujets avec lequel on
peut toujours débattre
voilà avec lequel alors il il hésite
jamais non plus à manier ce qu'il faut
dans le débat politique
la mauvaise foi y tenait il sait comment
ne pas répondre à une question quand il
en a pas envie je crois que c'est un
parlementaire tout à fait respectable
que je ne connais pas personnellement
mais en tout cas qui est d'une fidélité
à son
patron si j'ose dire puisqu'il s'est mis
dans la dans le sillage de françois
fillon observait la politique c'est une
course de fond c'est pas simplement un
coup de coup c'est la ténacité et je
crois qu'il est assez tenace pour y
arriver
bon on espère que contrairement à ce que
dit bruno les rouges n'avait pas esquivé
nos questions et la mauvaise foi vous
l'avez beaucoup rencontré cette semaine
non c'est pas rencontré beaucoup de
mauvaises ford dans un corps non non
j'ai rencontré des visions différentes
si on veut parler de mise
j'ai rencontré puisqu'on parle bien sûr
uniquement de ce qui se passe à l'ump on
va sans doute parlé tout à l'heure sur
d'autres sujets mais pour pour revenir à
ce qui se passe à l'ump non je n'ai pas
rencontré j'ai rencontré davos idées des
convictions
en revanche j'ai été peiné je vous le
dis par des propos que j'ai jugé
excessif qui n'était pas de mauvaise foi
mais qui était de l'excès des propos
désobligeants vis-à-vis de certains moi
je cherche toujours dans ma
responsabilité de porte parole de
françois fillon à préserver l'avenir
je sais qu'on est tous membres d'une
même famille qu'on est tous ensemble que
lorsqu'on sera sorti de cette tempête on
sera rassemblée on sera uni les français
nous le demandent les militants les
adhérents de l'ump nous le mans donc moi
je cherche toujours à b sur les
questions on a dit m
quelques difficultés à vous croire sur
le côté une idée mais on reviendra
évidemment là tu as titre à titre
personnel à titre personnel si vous
aviez un mot une phrase pour qualifier
ce qui s'est passé tout au long de cette
semaine de quel serait ce la tempête
dans la tempête on est dans la tempête
dans un verre d'eau ou des oeuvres étant
maintenant non c'est une vraie tempête
on le voit bien c'est pas une tempête
dans un verre d'eau c'est pas une
histoire qui concerne seulement quelques
personnes c'est pas une guerre
picrocholine c'est une vraie tempête
c'est une tempête de la plus grande
famille de la droite et du centre c'est
une tempête de la plus grande famille
politique de france en terme de nombre
d'adhérents c'est donc une vraie tempête
est dans la tempête il faut savoir
d'abord souquer ferme et ensuite
imaginer une sortie c'est la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs françois fillon a
tout de suite fait appel à alain juppé
et associés en train de regarder en lui
mais on va appeler ce qui s'appelle un
chat un chat et vous l'avez dit c'est
une tempête ou une guerre
alors lundi soir l'ump avait son
président jean françois copé les
résultats étaient entérinées puis
mercredi dans l'après-midi le ton a
subitement changé les fillonnistes son
parti à l'offensive entre contestation
des résultats et accusations en tous
genres récit d'une journée du chaos
thibault le floch mercredi à quelques
minutes des questions au gouvernement
les lieutenants de françois fillon ont
réuni les journalistes pour une annonce
choc
il s'agit d'une erreur manifeste est
grave
l'oubli pure et simple de ces trois
fédérations et de 1304 militants nous
demandons donc à la cour que que les
résultats soient simplement rétabli
après une nuit de recomptage laurent
wauquiez s'est rendu compte que les
votes des fédérations de nouvelle
calédonie mayotte et wallis et futuna
n'ont pas été pris en compte
jean françois copé arriverait ainsi 2e
de l'élection avec 26 voix de retard
mais face aux caméras ce dernier tempère
et menaces je pense vraiment que l'heure
est plutôt être raisonnable plutôt que
de recommencer à shikai est encore une
nouvelle fois
sans aucun élément est encore une fois
sinon côté commission des recours dont
on ira à une commission des recours s'il
faut les une commission des recours puis
comme ça que ça permettra de regarder
aussi de plus près les résultats à nice
et puis voilà selon copé les
fillonnistes pourrait s'en mordre les
doigts s'ils recompte les voix et que
des bourrages d'urnes sont constatées
notamment à nice la circonscription
d'eric ciotti
mais les soutiens de fillon sont bien
décidés à ne pas se laisser
impressionner
c'est incroyable mais c'est ainsi alors
nous voulons que la commission
comptabilise ses trois départements et
que la commission proclament des
résultats complets nouvelle réplique de
copé qui se pose cette fois en
rassembleur
j'appelle françois fillon et ceux qui le
conseille surtout ceux qui le conseille
à retrouver le sens des responsabilités
et de l'intérêt général
pendant ce temps sur le plateau de tf1
françois fillon donne l'impression
d'avoir reçu le message
je ne revendique pas la présidence de
l'ump je renonce à la présidence de
l'ump a mais renoncer ne veut pas dire
qu'ils souhaitent voir jean françois
copé à la tête de l'ump
tel que je demande c'est qu'alain juppé
parce que c'est une personnalité
incontestable constitue une équipe qui
regroupera l'ensemble des responsables
de notre famille politique et nous
propose une sortie de crise j'irai
jusqu'au bout
si personne n'écoute ce que je demande
si on n'est pas en place une équipe
provisoire pour diriger l'ump
alors oui je déposerai un recours devant
la justice quelques minutes plus tard
sur le plateau de france 2 jean françois
copé réplique je ne peux pas imaginer
qu'il aille à une telle extrémité c'est
pour ça que je dis que je suis prêts
bien sûr à parler avec lui voilà la
conclusion de cette soirée un jean
françois copé est prêt à discuter mais
certainement pas à lâcher le fauteuil de
président de l'ump
alors ça c'était mercredi suite du
feuilleton jeudi tout le monde a l'air
d'accord pour revoir les résultats
le tout est de savoir quelle place va
prendre alain juppé dans le dispositif
commission de recours commission
spéciale c'est la guerre des
propositions sur fond d' ultimatum
d'alain juppé nouveau jour nouvelle saga
résumé par jean baptiste douglas c'était
la journée de la contre attaque pour
jean françois copé
à midi il dévoile sa stratégie saisir
de lui-même la commission des recours de
l'ump je propose que des représentants
de chacun des candidats puissent
assister en tant qu'observateurs à ces
travaux ainsi d'ailleurs que des
personnalités indépendantes
je pense en particulier s'il veut bien
accepter
alain juppé mais le maire de bordeaux ne
veux pas être instrumentalisé
il propose de prendre la tête d'une
commission indépendante mettons en place
une instance extra statutaire mais à
partir du moment où les deux parties
sont d'accord n'y a aucun problème pour
que cette instance composée de
représentants des deux candidats et de
personnalités qui ne se sont pas engagés
la data est comme moi par exemple crise
en s'appuyant sur la commission de
contrôle des opérations électorales et
sur la commission des encours faire le
point clarifier la situation
à l'assemblée le camp fillon s'empresse
d'approuver la commission juppé quelques
heures plus tard le directeur de cabinet
de jean françois copé c'est une
conférence de presse et photocopier à
l'appui il accuse le camp fillon de
tricherie à nice ou en nouvelle
calédonie voici les documents qui le
prouvent
avant de donner la réponse de
jean-françois copé à la proposition
d'alain juppé jean françois copé est
prêt à accepter le verdict qui sera
prononcé par monsieur alain juppé qui
permettra de rétablir la vérité des
chiffres total sur l'élection voilà la
médiation juppé acceptée par le clan
copé
mais pour les partisans de françois
fillon le diable se loge dans les
détails
chez lavery yeux a dit
on commence par la commission des
recours qui va se prononcer et monsieur
juppé pourra ensuite regarder cette
commission des recours vous voyez bien
ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'en
réalité c'est une commission à sa main
qui va valider les résultats à sa main
et alain juppé ne sera que n'arrivera
qu'en 2 yannick après la guerre du
recomptage des bulletins
place aux querelle d'interprétation sur
ce que doit être la commission juppé moi
je regarde le communiqué d'alain juppé
alain juppé dit c'est écrit en toutes
lettres c'est pas moi qui l'inventé il
dit je propose une instance que je
présiderai s'appuyant sur les travaux de
la coco et et sur les travaux de la
commission des recours
c'est clair quoi qu'il en soit alain
juppé se disait jeudi soir convaincus
que les conditions étaient réunies pour
exercer sa mission
ses conclusions seront connues sous 15
jours et nous a rejoints sur ce plateau
jérôme sainte marie bonjour vous êtes
directeur général adjoint de l'institut
de sondage csa avec vous afin de
comprendre d'analyser de décrypter ce
psychodrame
alors d'abord on va revenir avoue jérôme
chartier c'est pas si clair que ça comme
on le comme certains le disaient dans le
sujet comprenez pour le commun des
mortels c'est un peu compliqué à
comprendre
alors il ya en parallèle une commission
des recours qui va travailler et une
commission indépendante présidée par
alain juppé jusque là nous sommes
d'accord d'ailleurs là pour le coup tout
le monde est d'accord avec ça c'est pas
des commissions parallèle il ya une
seule commission et moi j'ai entendu ce
qu'a dit le collaborateur de jean
françois copé
d'ailleurs j'aurais préféré que ce soit
jean françois copé lui-même qui exprime
ça aurait été plus simple direct plus
clair mais bon copé ce qu'il a dit moi
là pour le coup et je crois que tout le
monde est d'accord c'est que la
commission présidée par alain juppé et
la commission souveraine absolue qui
indiquera qui l'a emporté après l'examen
de tous les recours après l'exécution
des recours n'existe pas pour vous mais
pour nous de toute façon l'a toujours
dit qu'une seule commission france a
coûté la vie
commission qu'elle nous l'avons toujours
dit c'est un cafouillage aragorn oh non
non non précisant les choses nous
l'avons toujours dit il ya qu une seule
commission
c'est la commission qui est présidée par
alain juppé et en l'occurrence et devant
de nouveau cette commission que nous
allons déposer toutes les remarques les
observations sur les irrégularités que
l'on a pu constater tant pendant le
déroulement de la campagne que pendant
le déroulement du scrutin
c'est ce que nous allons faire c'est la
commission que nous avons souhaité c'est
la commission qu'alain juppé a accepté
c'est la commission qui d'après ce qu'on
a saisi a été acceptée par jean françois
copé comme la commission qui était
compétente s'agissant du verdict nous
entend la commission de recours peut
bien travailler vous ne tiendrait pas
compte de leur avis mais de toute façon
c'est pas à nous de tenir compte ou pas
tenir compte de l'avis de la commission
c'est un ajouté donc ce n'est pas pas
d'autres responsabilités c'est pas nous
qui sommes jugement dernier en cours
mais lorsqu'on voit le fonctionnement
j'irai de la commission de contrôle des
opérations électorales qui pardon a
quand même réussi la performance
d'oublier le résultat de trois
fédérations qui inversent le scrutin
vous comprendrez qu'on ait de sérieux
doutes sur le fonctionnaire va tout
client interne de l'ump jérôme sainte
marie
est ce que vous comprenez encore quelque
chose aujourd'hui
ça augure aussi nos jours très
difficiles et c'est un grand cafouillage
au sein de ce parti là c'est clair
depuis quelques heures en fait c'est
qu'on est sorti du champ à mon avis
c'est sous ce n'était pas forcément
d'accord on est sorti du champ du
règlement ou de la loi pour entrer en
changeant la légitimité c'est à dire que
on a effectivement des raisonnements
pratiquement juridique qui s'affrontent
dans cette affaire avec les communiqués
de coco et partir dans l'étrange
d'ailleurs récemment disant que oui
effectivement probablement le résultat
sera inversé mais que le règlement ne
permet pas d'en tenir compte si j'ai
bien compris lui et on fait un
communiqué pour ça qu'on est dans le
juridique c'est un second étant
juridique il redevient en politique fait
appel à quelqu'un il n'ya pas sûr que ce
soit à fait prévu dans les statuts mais
en fait il ya il ya un accord pour un
blocage politique total et donc on fait
appel à quelqu'un qui a pour sa pop et
de respecter les statuts et vous ne
voulez plus parce que
confiance on finira en sortir ce blocage
effectivement on essaie d'en sortir par
le haut à l'ump en faisant appel à
quelqu'un qui est reconnue comme
légitime cette légitimité il la tient de
sa de son passé politique sont présents
politique aussi et de voilà et puis
également de sa très forte image dans
l'opinion en général dans l'opinion de
l'ump en particulier il ya un sondage
qu'elle est sortie d'ailleurs hier qui
montre que 95 % des sympathisants de
l'ump c'est harris interactive qui se
fait se félicite de leur l'entrée dans
le jeu je vais alain juppé donc on voit
bien que ça se calme le seul élément
essentiel est là et là du coup il ya on
est sur un choix politique que vous ne
pouvez pas vous en tant d'entre vous que
ce soit françois fillon ou jean françois
copé vous êtes obligés de faire appelle
donc à la statue du commandeur a
finalement alain juppé c'est lui le seul
qui peut dépatouiller un petit peu tout
ça mais si nous avions une organisation
de l'ump qui soit totalement
indépendantes dans le déroulement de la
campagne pour la présidence de l'ump
nous pourrions nous référer à l or
qu'est-ce qu'on a observée en permanence
qu'il y avait confusion des genres entre
le candidat jean françois copé et le
secrétaire général jean françois copé
l'organisation de début et finalement
vous auriez dû demander à ce que jean
françois copé devenu secrétaire général
de demander à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
confusion des genres est
incontestablement ça a été encore plus
loin qu'on pouvait l'imaginer
soit on n'a pas revenir ni pleurer sur
le lait renversé c'est comme ça
maintenant nous sommes dans une nouvelle
phase et c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous faisons appel à une personne
incontestable et incontesté pour qui
chaque titre personnel une immense
admiration et qui est on a fondé l'ump
il y a dix ans pour justement fermé la
porte à ce qu'on appelait la droite la
plus bête du monde
c'est à dire qu'il n'entendait jamais or
là tout le monde a envie de dire c'est
le retour de la droite la plus bête du
monde eh ben vous dis non et pourquoi je
vous dis non parce que marie-laure parce
que justement on a décidé de ne rien
régler
derrière la porte c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas de petits règlements de compte
tout est mis sur la table tout est dit
c'est la transparence que l'on souhaite
c'est la transparence jusqu'au bout au
c'est vrai parfois c'est pas très drôle
parfois c'est un peu la partie les
adhérents et les militants d'une ip
parfois peuvent de leur reprocher sauf
que la vie a changé on demande de la
transparence alors il ya apparemment
temps où il y aurait de la transparence
et un mot manque de temps ou ne voudrais
pas de transparence la transparence
c'est comme ça par an ce qui ressemble à
un grand déballage on pense par exemple
à la conférence de presse de jérôme
l'algérie après bourse jeudi après midi
jérôme lavrilleux qui montrent des
documents je trouverais là les fraudes
j'y reviens notamment dans les alpes
maritimes ça c'était au grand déballage
mais moi je viens d'une famille
politique qui s'appelait le rpr à
l'époque du rpr on avait l'habitude de
connaître le candidat qui était élu
président du rpr avant même que le
scrutin ait lieu
moi je suis content d'être aujourd'hui
dans une famille politique où on doit
attendre quelques jours avant d'avoir le
résultat définitif c'est plus difficile
c'est parfois un peu plus rude mais en
tout cas c'est transparent et c'est
légitime
et cette élection doit sortir par le
haut d'une façon incontestable et
incontesté jérôme sainte-marie qu'est ce
que vous en pensez transparent grand
déballage wilno on va partir mais sur ce
point là je rentre chartier a évidemment
raison d'accord c'est bien sûr qu'on a
une exigence de transparence toute la
société française pas uniquement sur le
politique d'ailleurs et qui dit
transparence dit aussi juridisme et
respect des formes
on voit bien que dans un parti autrefois
il ya pas si longtemps il ya quelques
années
le fait qu'ils aient quelques milliers
de votes oubliés dans des fédérations
d'outre-mer n'aurait pas posé des
problèmes d'insurmontable or là ça rend
la proposition de l'actuel secrétaire
général joue à quelques papas résidence
et selon les camps eh bien ça rend la
situation jean françois copé
pratiquement à table parce que il peut
pas être les totalement légitime si on
la coco et reconnaît à demi mot qui en
fait il est minoritaire même si
effectivement aucune force armée ne peut
le sortir de son bureau
donc c'est bien pour cela qu'on est dans
cette île qu'on est obligé de recourir à
alain juppé c'est pour sortir de cette
impasse mais qu'est créée par
l'évolution des moeurs politiques plutôt
dans le bon sens en l'occurrence
alors évidemment ce mauvais climat se
ressent dans les deux assemblées
mercredi un jour du coup de force des
fillonistes les quatre colonnes à
l'assemblée à son le théâtre privilégié
du vaudeville fillonniste écopé il se
croise celle ville 12 ans faisait partie
d'ailleurs il parle beaucoup aux
journalistes elisa bartholomé à
l'assemblée fillonniste échos pays se
sont livrés à une vraie partie de ping
pong
peu avant 15h les
soutien de françois fillon attaque salle
des quatre colonnes en nombre ils
délivrent leur message aux journalistes
trois fédérations mayotte wallis et
futuna et la nouvelle calédonie n'ont
pas été pris en compte dans le décompte
des voix pour la présidence de l'ump je
ne doute pas un seul instant que pour
nous permettre de sortir de cette crise
jean françois copé accepte que dans
cette période transitoire
alain juppé puisse prendre la direction
de notre mouvement a pris de court les
député copéiste pen a riposté il faut
presque attendre la fin des questions au
gouvernement pour que les soutiens du
nouveau président de l'ump renvoie leur
adversaire dans les cordes 6 estime
qu'il ya encore un recours à faire avec
qui le forme et on verra bien mais à ce
moment là on vous savez des recours il
peut y en avoir aussi de toutes parts je
pense par exemple à nice mais on sait
bien qu'il ya eu des choses un peu
bizarre qui sont passées à nice
objectivement les résultats ont été
proclamés
maintenant on peut aussi réouvrir les
650 bureaux de vote tout ça n'a plus de
sens
moi je demande à françois fillon de
siffler la fin de la récréation la récré
eux la connaissent bien ce vaudeville à
l'ump rappelle quelques souvenirs aux
députés socialistes qui sans annulation
l'ump et l assemblée nationale les
questions gouvernement était plus animé
là aujourd'hui on voit qu'il était
absolument concentrer sur les vingt-six
mois de wallis et futuna et que la
direction du pays ne les intéressait pas
et nous on a du travail
il faut qu'on va le rester comptes du
pays les comptes du pays c'est autrement
plus importants que les comptes
d'apothicaire à l'ump lassé de ces
querelles 134 députés ump appel à la
médiation d'alain juppé pas sûr que le
groupe soit encore complet la semaine
prochaine alors le groupe ump composé
294 députés à l'assemblée est ce que une
scission ne semble pas inévitable en
tout cas nous ça nous le semble à
l'heure actuelle du du fait de
l'acceptation par alain juppé de la
présidence de cette commission et du
fait que cette commission soit vote
aujourd'hui acceptée par jean françois
copé on a échappé à toute situation
dangereuse pour l'unité de l'ump
incontestablement américain de confiance
et maintenant il parlait plus commence
comme la déraison tout ça c'était pas
vrai évidemment qu'on se parle de mafia
comme un célébrant très fort
grand exemple c'est que la semaine
dernière posant une question au
gouvernement sur la situation économique
de la france
j'avais à mon côté là des proches député
qui avait pris fait et cause pour jean
françois copé et qui me prenais mes
feuilles dont vous voyez vous la
question la question mais c'est pas ça
c'est que non mais soyons clairs paris
soyons clairs la question c'est
qu'aujourd'hui chacun a pris bien sûr
fait et cause pour un candidat et donc
les relations sont naturellement plus
tendu mais nous sommes d'accord sur
l'essentiel
nous sommes d'accord sur la ligne
politique nous sommes d'accord sur les
valeurs que l'on défend par conséquent à
l'issue de la tempête
si on obtient bien ce résultat
incontestable et incontesté pour
l'élection à la présidence de l'ump ce
qui sera le cas du fait de la commission
juppé on se retrouvera tous ça c'est le
concept du mal à vous croire là-dessus
camions qui ont été échangés tu viens
vous quand on a eu si vous voulez bien
moi je ne crois pas versement que le
risque d'une scission ce si grand que
cela apprend un exemple quand inverse ou
tout simplement le parti socialiste qui
a vu les congrès socialiste parti du
congrès de reims
mais pour l'opl évidemment mais les
congrès où effectivement pendant
plusieurs jours les affrontements
étaient terribles héros en plus les
querelles de personnes étaient conviées
à ces querelles de personnes
s'additionner des clivages idéologiques
profond et pourtant on a il n'y a pas eu
une scission et au départ de jean pierre
chevènement à une époque mais c'est la
seule dont celui qui souffre aussi de
temps presse d'autant plus qu'on ne voit
pas se dégager très clairement quand
même deux camps idéologiques au sein de
l'ump à ce qu'elles sont là c'est la
question est celle du pouvoir mais à
l'état pur c'est d'ailleurs pour ça il
ya une droite décomplexée contre une
boîte un petit peu plus si on met des
différences de style mais cherchait à
billes et cela avec des oripeaux
idéologiques me paraît très difficile
c'est d'ailleurs ce que les français
vous reproche moi je suis je moi je suis
assez lasse je suis d'accord avec cette
analyse
nous sommes d'accord sur l'essentiel il
y a une façon de faire la politique
incontestable qui est différente entre
jean-françois copé et françois fillon
c'est incontestable il y à aussi
s'agissant des valeurs oui nous les
partageons après il ya la façon
d'exprimer les valeurs et là nous sommes
en désaccord mais ce qui a été dit est
d'ailleurs par françois fillon le
premier c'est qu'il y aura besoin
l'issue de cette tempête
ils ont rassemblé toute la famille est
là le rassemblement ça ne va pas se
décréter non non non on n'a pas compris
mais non pourquoi bon pourquoi est-ce
qu'on n'a pas compris parce qu'on a
l'impression que tout ça c'est juste de
la forme c'est juste de la langue de loi
or c'est parce que je veux dire ce que
je veux dire c'est qu'il y aura besoin
d'une direction collégiale s'est
radicalement différent c'est pas juste
le rassemblement l'unité et les pâtes à
couffin non ça va plus loin une
direction collégiale ça veut dire qu'il
faudra à l'issue de toute façon
lorsqu'il ya un écart aussi faible entre
deux candidats au sein d'une même
famille il faut qu entre direction
collégiale ça veut dire que tout le
monde se mette d'accord pour diriger
ensemble ump c'est ça au fond qui va
être difficile mais c'est ça qu'on saura
surmonter est très rapide en effet un
sondage cette semaine vous êtes projeter
sur 2010 est donc nicolas sarkozy
arriverait largement devant avec 52%
françois fillon 24 jean françois copé 15
son choix des sympathisants ump faut
bien le dire
sondage réalisé après la contestation
des résultats mais avant goût de force
de mercredi ne pas aimer décidément jean
françois copé au moins auprès des
sympathisants parle pas des militants du
renseignement le premier effectivement
c'est jean françois copé alors même
qu'il était à ce moment-là président a
contesté quand tu fais un contexte et
une protestation mais en tout cas il y
avait le nez pas découvert des bulletins
de vote etc non prise en compte
et bien pourtant il était en effet un
score très bas on sait que dans
l'opinion en général et même parmi les
sympathisants de droite son image est
tout à fait bien moindre en tout cas en
qualité et que celle de françois fillon
le second enseignement le principal
c'est quand même que nicolas sarkozy
apparaissait déjà à l'époque et quelques
jours comme le candidat naturel en
quelque sorte de son camp pour
l'élection de 2017
or c'était avant ce qui s'est passé à
bordeaux hier le fait que le conte ses
soucis judiciaires semblent un peu
s'éloigner et le fat east également que
que la crise et approfondie et que donc
la légitimité du futur président cissé
jean françois copé françois fillon sera
nécessairement amoindri oui nicolas
sarkozy c'est le grand gagnant ou pas
c'est de fait c'est le grand gagnant par
défaut de cette affaire est-ce que vous
pensez que nicolas sarkozy doit
intervenir pour régler cette affaire par
communiqués par façon d'une hôtesse qui
doit intervenir et surtout maintenant
c'était
vous dites et le taf et enfin en tout
cas la question de l'élection de
présidence de l'ump est en voie de
règlement
puisqu'elle a jusqu'à accepter la
présidence de cette commission puisque
la commission qu'il va composer va être
une commission incontestable et qu'elle
va pouvoir travailler et produire un
résultat définitif c'est tout ce que
nous demandions donc aujourd'hui la
situation à l'ump est en voie de
règlement
nous sommes en train de sortir de la
tempête nous sommes en train de voir la
manière qui sait qu'il y en a qui
profitent d'un petit peu de cette
tempête c'est jean louis borloo il veut
devenir la principale force d'opposition
en tout cas contre vous c'est et les
explications de jérémy hartmann
il est le premier à avoir claqué la
porte
pierre méhaignerie ancien ministre ump a
décidé de quitter son parti pour
rejoindre les centristes de lui dit
j'estime qu'il y à des discours qui ne
sont pas acceptables
je pense que le pays a besoin de raisons
de sérénité et je rappelle aussi qu' à
3,5 millions cinq cent mille français
d'origine étrangère qui ont besoin de
beaucoup de considération le virage à
droite de jean françois copé inquiète
certains parlent de fracture morale sur
tf1 l'intéressé a tenté de minimiser la
faire c'est à regret mais n'y avait pas
de surprise en revanche il y a une
sensibilité centriste très importante à
l'ump
incarnée par marc philippe daubresse
avec à ses côtés des personnalités comme
jean pierre raffarin luc chatel michèle
tabarot christian kert et bien d'autres
pas certain que cette posture rassure
les fillonnistes et les centristes
une dizaine de parlementaires ump se
sont réunis ils réfléchissent aussi à
quitter le parti
l'hémorragie va-t-elle s'amplifier elle
pourrait en tout cas profité à lui d i
le parti centriste espère récupérer les
déçus de jean françois copé
même si officiellement jean louis borloo
refuse de se réjouir du psychodrame de
ses partenaires de droite
on n'est pas vrai
et copé n'y en ait pas de débauchage il
ya clairement on a toujours dit la même
chose de chouette on bâtir une coalition
de photons être gagnant de cette
collection
en coulisses les élus de l'ue dei se
frotte les mains
il affirme avoir reçu 2400 adhésion de
nouveaux militants ces dernières 48
heures vous comprendriez jérôme chartier
que certains quittent aujourd'hui l'ump
déçu par tout ce qui se passe pour
aujourd'hui 10
c'est un peu ce qu'a fait pierre
méhaignerie plus maintenant et il l'a
fait qu'on pille améliorée il l'a fait
le moment du vote
mais au moment de l'annoncé du vote de
cinq ans juste après le vote c'est à
dire au fond lorsque nous nous avions un
sentiment que nous l'avions emporté nous
ne voulions pas faire de recours puisque
nous n'avions déposé aucun recours
puisque nous avions pris acte de la
décision de la commission de contrôle
des opérations électorales
mais la question va se poser à l'issue
de la proclamation des résultats par la
commission juppé qu'est ce qui va se
passer et pourquoi pierre méhaignerie ne
reviendrait pas dans une ump
transparente avec les résultats
contestables et avec et avec surtout
avec surtout une commune avec surtout
une direction excusez moi j'y reviens
avec une direction sous forme de colis
choc de coalition de collégialité qui
est le grand gagnant du pays où le front
national
bon on ne sait pas encore on ne sait pas
encore puisque effectivement on voit
bien que si jean françois copé été
confirmée in fine est à la tête de l'ump
ça profiterait plus tôt à lui dit et
inversement si c'était françois fillon
ça le front national recueillerait
peut-être peut-être mais ça c'est la
projection ce qui est certain c'est
qu'au delà des élus il faut voir comme
les électeurs les sympathisants est
actuellement 23 % des français qui se
considère comme sympathisant de l'ump
nous verrons la semaine prochaine
combien seront vous envisagé l'hypothèse
d'un françois fillon au président l'ump
mais si on a bien entendu ce qui se
disait qu'elle mardi soir sur tf1
françois fillon disait qu'il renonçait à
la présidence de l'ump on a mal compris
dont vous n'avez pas compris puisqu'il
ne sera pas la seule chose c'est que
françois fillon va se plier à la
décision de la commission présidée par
alain juppé mais ce qu'a voulu dire
françois fillon devant des millions de
téléspectateurs
c'est que une ump qui est séparée entre
les deux candidats d'une poignée de voix
n'est pas l'ump avec un vainqueur
incontestable
largement et puis de l'autre côté
quelqu'un qui n'a pas gagné c'est donc
forcément lui et je le redis je le redis
je leur dis depuis tout à l'heure c'est
la direction c'est forcément la
direction collégiale qui sortira de
toute façon il n'y a pas d'alternative
possible pour rassembler le président
anouma il y aura un président c'est
évident abc et qui sera désigné par la
commission juppé président parce que ça
ce qu'avait proposé très attaché à la
france affirmé après sa vie sociale
c'est pape c'est pas pareil j'y reviens
si vous le voulez bien
le rassemblement le rassemblement c'est
un camp qui a gagné et qui élargit de
telle sorte que l'autre ne se sentent
pas totalement mise à l'écart mais une
direction collégiale c'est le partage
des responsabilités
c'est bien de cela dont il s'agit et en
l'occurrence la décision de la
commission présidée par la jupe et sera
souveraine et chacun soupirail françois
fillon l'a dit il a redit encore la
question c'est que françois fillon n'a
pas renoncé à être président de l'ump si
les conditions sont remplies si pas si
les conditions sont remplies ici surtout
si elle ajouté le lui demande
il se pliera à la presse que lui moudre
à la jupe et jérôme sainte marie on vous
libère merci d'être venu avec nous pour
commenter cette semaine mouvementée
jérôme chartier vous restez avec nous
pour commenter les autres termes de
l'actualité oui il ya eu une autre
actualité cette semaine et oui le mardi
par exemple une nouvelle reculade du
président hollande elle est passée un
peu inaperçue à grâce ou à cause d'eux
en ce mardi donc françois hollande se
rend au congrès des maires qui se tient
à paris très conciliant président il
veut laisser le temps au maire de
s'organiser autour des rythmes scolaires
et puis surtout il leur dit que sur le
mariage homosexuel et bien les élus ont
droit à la liberté de conscience
c'est un sujet de rabbi cas les maires
seront en première ligne si la loi qui
autorise le mariage pour tous est votée
alors françois hollande lors de leur
congrès a jugé bon d'aborder le thème
ils l'affirment le mariage pour tous
reste un de ses engagements mais il émet
quelques réserves
la loi s'applique pour tous dans le
respect néanmoins de la liberté de
conscience
les maires sont divisés sur la question
d'un côté il ya ceux qui refusent de
célébrer ces unions
il demande qu'une clause de conscience
et veulent faire jouer leur droit de
retrait de l'autre il ya ces mères qui
appliqueront la loi quelle que soit leur
opinion
je suis dans l'obligation de le faire ce
mariage
évidemment je ferai par contre si j'ai
des adjoints qui sont plus à même que
moi de vouloir faire ce mariage c'est
vraiment avec plaisir que je leur confie
ray cette tâche je ne céderai pas de
mariage homosexuel et je ne demanderais
au calme et des adjoints auxi municipal
de le faire un homme une femme
c'est la base à foyer c'est la base une
famille et je ne crois pas que la loi
puisse faire la nature
pris entre deux feux le président de
l'association des maires tentent de
trouver un compromis entre le respect de
la loi et les convictions personnelles
de chacun j'ai proposé des pistes à
commission des lois élargir le périmètre
au sein duquel on pourrait se marier
non pas seulement dans la communion on
habite mais aussi où habitent les
parents
donc ça fait plusieurs communes
complémentaires à voir également la
possibilité pour un maire de délégués
donc en fonction de l'empêchement
physiques ou moraux à ses adjoints à ses
conseillers municipaux
si la loi passe malgré tous ces
aménagements si un élu refuse de
célébrer ces unions il risque des
sanctions disciplinaires et des
poursuites pénales et le lendemain le
même françois hollande a retiré cette
expression de liberté de conscience donc
si l'on comprend bien tout le monde est
d'accord au sein du gouvernement et à la
présidence pour dire qu' il faut
célébrer les mariages vous même vous
êtes maire de domont dans l'oise
est-ce que vous célébrerez vous même des
mariages homosexuels si carla et moi je
suis républicain et donc j'ai respecté
les lois de mon pays comme le font
certains pour tout vous dire c'est
qu'avant de respecter les lois de mon
pays je vais me battre comme jamais pour
m'opposer à ce mariage entre deux
personnes du même sexe a dit tout oui
dans l'hémicycle et pas du tout pour des
questions quelle qu'elle soit pour un
seul principe on peut s'aimer et se
marier mais on peut et c'est aussi
s'aimer sans se marier
donc si on décide de se marier c'est
pour pouvoir fonder une famille une
famille c'est les points de repère s'il
sait
si vous a plu c'est important justement
qu'est-ce que vous appliquerez vous
qu'est ce qui est très important c'est
ma conviction est ma conviction c'est
que si on peut s'aimer sans se marier si
on décide de se marier c'est pour fonder
une famille c'est pour construire
quelque chose et c'est tout le sens du
mariage le sens du mariage c'est donc
par conséquent la filiation et
l'application pour moi est un pro est
une affaire qui est absolument centrale
dans la vie française
autrement dit un jeune au calme qu'on
battrait à l'assemblée nationale je
combattrai non seulement à l'assemblée
mais aussi en dehors de l'assemblée pour
faire reconnaître que ce problème n'est
pas une question d'amour je suis
d'ailleurs pour le renforcement et même
pour une cérémonie pour le pacs je ne
vois aucune difficulté à cela mais en
revanche l'institution du mariage est
une institution pour construire une
famille ouverte à une famille et des
enfants et l'adoption délégué à vos
adjoints
il affiche un air de 120 questions et
l'adoption par un couple du même sexe
d'enfants est aujourd'hui une question
qui pose un problème la société
française et pour laquelle j'observe que
l'essentiel du français est opposée
aujourd'hui et on continue avec toujours
l'inquiétude des maires et oui les
maires sont inquiets ils s'inquiètent
pour les finances à l'heure où le chef
de l'état a décidé un tour de vis
budgétaire
eh bien ils n'arrivent plus tout
simplement à faire face dans les
couloirs du congrès des maires c'est un
reportage de mathilde bélanger c'était
il ya quelques semaines le maire de
sevran planter sa tente devant
l'assemblée nationale et c'est cette
s'alimenter afin d'obtenir de meilleurs
moyens financiers pour sa commune une
action extrême qui a mis en lumière les
inégalités entre les collectivités et
les difficultés auxquelles font face
certains maires réunis à paris cette
semaine ils sont nombreux à se dire au
bout de leurs capacités nous avons
d'énormes difficultés financières
si bien que les investissements ne peut
pas les faire
parce que l'endettement va peser sur un
nombre de foyers relativement réduit ce
serait énorme
donc on ne peut pas faire grand chose
dans les petites communes dans ces
communes on s'inquiète donc de l'effort
de rigueur demandée par le gouvernement
aux collectivités territoriales et des
dotations de l'état diminueront
d'environ 8 milliards d'euros l'an
prochain pour participer au redressement
des comptes publics
les messages ils sont aussi condamnés
comme l'état à maîtriser la dépense
unique par contre nous lisions l'état
c'est que on ne peut pas continuer à
voir une baisse de dotation avec une
augmentation de charge et un effet
ciseau qui reste infernale
il ya des communes pour qui les corps
quand on demandera sera totalement
anodin on s'en apercevra même pas à la
nuitée des communes qui sont les
communes dites pauvres qui ont déjà
sollicité beaucoup il en prend les
choses comme ça se disent on a atteint
on a un talent aussi vous vous permettez
cette expression
françois hollande a confirmé hier cet
effort demandé aux collectivités mais il
lâche du lest sur certains points de
friction comme la réforme des rythmes
scolaires
les communes qui n'auront pas les moyens
de l'appliquer cette année pourront
attendre la rentrée suivante est un
fonds spécifique de 250 millions d'euros
sera mise en place pour accompagner les
corrige les plus endurcis qualité alors
jérôme chartier je le rappelle vous êtes
secrétaire de la commission des finances
ici à l'assemblée nationale vous êtes le
maire d'une petite commune est ce que
vous pensez que ces petites communes les
plus pauvres devraient être exemptés de
l'effort national
non non non non je fais on doit pas mon
bafa river doit participer à l'effort
national on ne peut pas si vous voulez
avoir un discours sur la réduction de la
dépense publique qui s'arrêtent aux
frontières de sa commune ça n'aurait
aucune cohérence et les français
d'ailleurs nous le reprocherait ils
auraient raison de nous le reprocher
donc vous attendez qu'ils n'arrivent
plus on y arrive plus tout simplement à
joindre les deux bouts
mais l'exercice est difficile et je le
reconnais la seule chose c'est que il
faut faire oeuvre de bonne gestion alors
pas de bonne gestion seulement depuis
deux ans moi je suis mère maintenant
depuis 1995 ça fait 17 ans je suis vert
et depuis dix sept ans j'essaye de
pratiquer la bonne gestion depuis 17 ans
j'ai pas augmenter les taux d'imposition
de ma commune et j'essaye de faire que
de montville de 15000 habitants soit
toujours une commune attractive où il
fait bon vivre
donc c'est difficile l'exercice est très
difficile
ce qu'a annoncé françois hollande
notamment sur les normes et on a plus de
400 mille en france ça va dans le bon
sens tout ça oui c'est quelque chose
qu'on a demandé d'ailleurs c'est quelque
chose qu'elle connaît bien des petites
ficelles c'est vrai je connaissais tout
d'abord ça c'est très important c'est
quelque chose qu'elle est proposée
nicolas sarkozy pendant sa campagne
présidentielle donc moi je suis content
qu'aujourd'hui françois leroy y ait
quelque chose comme quoi parfois
françois hollande est capable de bonnes
choses il est capable de reprendre les
bonnes propositions nicolas sarkozy
j'aurais voulu qu'il fasse la même chose
pour la tva compétitivité servette est
formidable et un petit peu ce que je dis
là le budget 2013 qui arrive au sénat
est avec toujours toutes les chances
d'être toqué le sénat a lieu de tous les
dangers pour le gouvernement à cause de
l'opposition communiste trois textes ont
déjà été retoqué dont le plfss le projet
de loi de finances de sécurité sociale
alors le projet de loi de finances pour
2013 qui arrive en ce jeudi a toutes les
chances d'emprunter le même chemin
explications de flora sauvage tous les
regards sont braqués sur les communistes
cette fois ci les sénateurs du front de
gauche devraient s'abstenir
après avoir voté contre le projet de loi
de finances de la sécurité sociale
ils veulent donner un signal clair à
leurs alliés socialistes on est vraiment
dans une posture de construction et non
pas dans une posture de roger pour
rejeter chez les socialistes on veut
croire que les ponts ne sont pas coupés
avec les alliés communistes
je leur ai demandé d'avoir la cohérence
sur la partie rochette et je vais encore
les appeler tout à l'heure à voter cette
partie recettes en s'abstenant sur la
première partie du texte la partie
recettes des communistes laisse la
possibilité de jours scrat et du projet
de loi jusqu'à son terme
mais l'abstention des vins fille nature
que nos miss ne devrait pas empêcher le
rejet du texte car ump et centristes ont
prévu de voter contre sofa changer
complètement speech est de votre contre
ce que je souhaite c'est qu'on puisse
aller jusqu'au bout de l'examen de ce
texte parce que notamment s'agissant des
dépenses nous avons des propositions à
faire
le volet recettes du projet de loi de
finances doit être voté mercredi
prochain au sénat donc les communistes
qui sont vous alliez inédit au sénat
dans votre opposition aux options
budgétaires du gouvernement
donc le texte repassera à l'assemblée
vous allez vous opposer une nouvelle
fois oui on s'opposera alors les
communistes de nos alliés c'est peut
être un peu rapide 10 ont en tout cas
qui sont aussi les opposants dans disons
qu'ils sont des opposants à l'actuelle
majorité s'est cependant bien différente
convenons-en de telle sorte que comme ça
on ne puisse pas imaginer quelconque
mélange des genres évidement il ne
manquerait plus que l'unpi s'allier aux
communistes nous avoue que l' affaire se
règle sur quelque chose quand même qui
trouve grâce à vos yeux dans ce projet
de loi de finances ou rien du tout est
ce que c'est ce que tout le monde entend
depuis le début le matraquage non je
voudrais pas donner le sentiment qu'on
jette tout en bloc c'est pas la vérité
évidemment il y a des bonnes choses dans
ce projet de budget simplement parce
qu'il ya des choses que l'actuelle
majorité poursuit
s'agissant de démarches qui ont été
engagés par l'ancienne majorité
donc bien sûr qu'il ya des bonnes choses
parce que c'est nous qui les avions mise
en place mais il y à des mesures
nouvelles pour l'essentiel qui consiste
en faire payer plus d'impôts et surtout
aux entreprises
un seul chiffre ces 20 milliards d'euros
en plus de fiscalité décidée dans ses
lois de finances pour les entreprises
c'est phénoménal
au moment où on cherche attire les
entreprises en france à ce que les
entreprises créent de l'emploi on leur
fait payer 20 milliards d'impôts en plus
bon bah écoutez c'est totalement
incohérent permet un plan de
compétitivité qui a été annoncé qui sera
effective dans un collectif budgétaire
on va le rappeler donc il n'est pas
encore dans ce projet figure encore vous
le dites pour 2014 donc l'enfer mais oui
le temps économique et le temps
politique sont d'autant qu'ils sont
radicalement différentes sous l' empire
de la majorité socialiste
il est temps qu on recolle le temps
politique et le temps économique c'est
ce que faisait françois fillon nicolas
sarkozy lorsque lorsqu'il décide
trois mois après la dégradation par
standard and poor's du triple à français
de lancer la tva compétitivité pour
faire baisser le coût du travail en
france
il montre la réaction du politique
immédiate pour coller au plus près du
temps économie 10 et cette semaine il
maudit et qu'est ce que fait la majorité
socialiste rien elle modifie absolument
pas son plan elle laisse toujours 2014
comme le cas pour son fameux plan de
compétitivité économique eh bien je suis
désolé je revois de le dire à tous les
français c'est un temps politique
nettement trop long c'est un temps
pendant lequel on va perdre des nues
i d'emplois jérôme chartier on va
changer de sujet pour cette fin de
semaine ça se fait que vous connaissez
bien sûr la modernisation de la vie
politique vous aviez écrire il n'ya pas
longtemps on va parler du vote blanc qui
n'est plus mule
les députés ont adopté ce jeudi une
proposition de loi de lui des i qui
permettra de comptabiliser tout
simplement ses bulletins en fait
eh bien on va les séparer des bulletins
nuls est-ce que ça va dans le bon sens
c'est ce que sera un vrai bois et pour
les futures élections selon écouter on
verra il faut simplement se méfier du
vote blanc moi je
j'ai eu une énorme réflexion s'agissant
du code blanc pourquoi parce qu'en même
temps je veux respecter le choix des
électeurs défoncer pour moi la
démocratie la chose la plus belle qu'on
puisse imaginer et d'un autre côté je ne
veux pas encourager le non choix il faut
choisir dans la vie le choix est
difficile
le choix parfois cornélien mais il faut
la suivre et la plus grande difficulté
de la vie tout court
c'est d'assumer ses choix n'ont pas
comptabiliser les votes blancs en voyez
vous je suis revenu sur une proposition
et je suis honnête avec vous que j'avais
pourtant fait dans livre en 2005
exactement j'en avais parlé j'étais au
départ pour la comptabilisation des
votes blancs et voyez aujourd'hui je
reviens sur ce que je pensais il ya sept
ans de cela maintenant parce que je
pense que mon avis il faut choisir
il ne faut pas légitimes et le non choix
légitime ou de non choix est une erreur
ou alors si on le fait dans ce cas là on
le fait comme en belgique on pousse
exercice jusqu'au bout ce qui signifie
qu'on n'a plus le droit de ne pas aller
voter
la contrepartie plus longs avec
l'obligation d'aller voter la
contrepartie du vote beurre c'est le
vote obligatoire
donc on reconnaît le vote blanc mais au
rang le vote obligatoire et dans ce cas
là moi je suis prêt à l'envisager mais
en revanche accepté l'abstention plus
accepter le vote blanc qui le non choix
c'est en réalité prendre le risque de
pénaliser la vie politique et d'une
façon générale la démocratie en
légitimant le fait de ne pas choisir
choisir c'est très dur mais la vie c'est
un choix oui mais est-ce qu'on peut
quand même comprendre que les lecteurs
soient parfois indécis notamment quand
on voit la semaine qui s'est écoulée
eh bien je suis d'accord avec vous on
peut comprendre les camps soit un
déficit
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
que les lecteurs soient obligés de voter
si on veut reconnaître le vote blanc
parce que lorsqu'il est indécis qu'est
ce qu'il fait aujourd'hui en vérité il
s'abstient
arrêtez avec nous tout au long de cette
émission merci beaucoup et on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine à doha
d'un labeur et à la semaine prochaine